[Music]
hey
it's us again we are back and sophie was
first today i know sophie
you got to be first somebody's got to be
and today it was you
what are we talking about today we are
talking about a movie called
cadaver cadaver we just watched it last
night well i watched it
you were kind of like yeah i don't think
i saw it you did but i don't think you
were looking at it
yeah maybe you start talking about oh oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the uh the post-apocalyptic one yeah
yeah
it's kind of like the
[Laughter]
i watched it off and on i got a feel for
it i liked it it was pretty cool
it's like um this was actually i didn't
know like going
in um i figured because it was like on
the some of the press materials it
spelled with a k so i said well it's got
to be like
i said it's not german because i could
hear them talking i'm like that doesn't
sound like german i said but it sounds
like that my guess was finnish i was
very close it's actually norwegian it's
a norwegian
horror movie uh and i guess this just
came to netflix
on october 22nd so very very recent
and uh yeah this was actually um the guy
i can't pronounce his
name but this was either his first or
second like feature film
and it's basically about there's a city
it's
it's almost like a fairy tale or a fable
kind of this is a very fable
type of movie so it's set in this city
where there has been some kind of
nuclear
disaster um they don't tell you whether
it was on purpose or on accident like
because all they all they kind of give
you that is like some old newspapers and
stuff and some of them
even say that like some of them say was
this an act of war was it just an
accident so
so nobody knows but it doesn't really
matter because
everybody is like the whole place is
[ __ ] it's like everything's a ruin
everyone is starving you don't really
know how long ago it happened
but everybody's like all up in the
cormack mccarthy [ __ ] it's like
everyone's starving to death everyone's
terrible there's dead people in the
street it's awful
so we're focusing on this one family and
um they're basically it's a husband and
wife and their
daughter alice and they're
they established kind of a thing at the
beginning where the wife
is kind of like i mean everything is
shitty obviously but
she's kind of like well you have to just
keep believing that things are going to
get better because otherwise like what
point is there or anything and the dad
is just like man [ __ ] that like
pollyanna [ __ ] or whatever so there's
like some [ __ ] tension going on there
so then um a
kind of a cart shows up like one of
those looks like the [ __ ] child
catcher from chitty chitty bang bang
if you guys remember that which
traumatized a whole generation of
children
um it was actually pretty scary for a
kids movie i gotta say
so this shows up in the street and
they're basically like hey we got this
theater and we got this big show um we
want everybody to come to this show
we'll give you a meal and everyone's
like little ears perk up because like i
said everyone's kind of starving and it
kind of sucks they're eating like cat
food cans and [ __ ]
so um so a lot of people so everybody
like
buys a ticket they don't really tell you
because i thought they were just giving
tickets away but then like she asked the
dude she's like well how much the
tickets and he just was basically
well how much have you got so i guess
it's basically you just give whatever
yeah and if you don't have anything
they'll just give you the tickets for
free because
now here's the thing it was starting
kind of slow so i wasn't really paying a
whole lot
yeah yeah when the [ __ ] was starting to
kick off that's when i started to pay a
little more attention
to it but you know a lot a lot of
watching a movie it has to do with your
state of mind my state of mind at the
time i really didn't care
but yeah as it went on i started you
know you know
yeah it's kind of like i mean it's a
horror movie but it's kind of like a
thriller mystery like i said it's almost
it almost has like a fairy tale
feel like it's really good this is a
beautiful
movie real good color palette and it
almost looks like something
happening in the 20s or something or 30s
at certain points and then you know what
i'm talking about
yeah i think it's the decor of where the
theater is and everything because
basically this theater
is all that's like because like i said
all around it is just like trashed
it's just like everything got nuked but
somehow
this hotel kind of um because i think
it's not a theater it's actually like a
big luxury hotel
and it kind of survived like in the
middle of all this [ __ ]
and everything is still like intact in
there so it's got like chandeliers and
electricity and i could
tell that the movie was kind of
influenced by a fallout the
video game fall out like fallout 4 or
fallout 3. it had a fallout feel to it
but it'd be kind of like a side mission
and fall out that was kind of horror
and some of the some of the missions are
kind of horror with yeah
in fall out kind of reminded me of that
but it had a
real good you know just looked good and
then it was uh
it was freaky man kind of torture porny
yeah because i and i was sitting there
saying it's like man even if the story
wasn't any good
it's like i could just sit and like look
at this movie all day long because i
loved like all the hot the long hallways
all the red
light and all that so it was just a
gorgeous gorgeous looking there's no
cinematography no hollywood [ __ ] in
it
it's it's a foreign film they get right
to the point you know what i mean
like yeah i mean product placement no
corporate angle to it
no political it's just this [ __ ]
horror movie well
yeah i mean more or less it's like i
said it's kind of like a fable
in the sense that you know here's this
you could read it as kind of like this
hotel is like the only it's almost kind
of like the magical castle
that's like in the middle of like all
this land of like peasants of like all
these people that are starving
and so all of these people get invited
to this place and even though
everybody knows that it's probably a bad
idea
because it's like too good to be true
but everyone also is kind of feeling
like well
what the [ __ ] else you gonna do i mean
they said they're gonna feed us it's
like how much worse can it be than this
[ __ ] that we're living in so even though
everyone's like suspicious
it seems like everybody goes yeah so
they get there the place is [ __ ]
beautiful they have like
waiters like with trays with the [ __ ]
you know
thing on it it's like so there's so they
have like this whole thing put together
and there's this very sinister dude
named matthias who's running the whole
[ __ ]
and he basically comes out and they do
they give them food
um and it's one thing about this movie
is
it's you're gonna know where it's going
because you know that no good
can come of this like as soon as the as
the guy comes in the [ __ ] cart and is
like hey come to the theater everybody's
like oh [ __ ]
it's not gonna be good however it's
gonna turn and you pretty much know
where it's gonna go
but i think that it makes up for it's
kind of like
being a little bit predictable just in
the visuals and
you know stylistically and the acting is
also really really good
so basically this little family they go
um
you know mathias is standing up there on
the stage saying you know eat all you
want whatever and then he's like this is
um an immersive theater experience he's
like so basically
he gives everybody at the tables like
all the
customers or the guests or whatever he
gives them all masks like and they're
all the same they're
like all these old gold masks there's
like everybody must wear these because
those are the only things that are
distinguishing you from the actors
that are in the play so basically what
you have to do is you have to
you know they give them the food then
they put on the masks
and you basically get to wander around
the hotel
and there are supposedly like scenes
going on like in different rooms of the
hotels and you can go and watch
whichever ones you want
so that's what ends up happening however
as the time goes on the one main family
at the center of it
the mom starts to notice that people are
going missing and she's not entirely
sure because matthias says something at
the beginning about how everything you
see
is an illusion or is part of the show
like everything so for a long time she's
just kind of like okay well people are
going missing and like there's weird
[ __ ] going on but you don't know how
much of it is like part of the
performance
and how much of it is like oh [ __ ] we're
all in trouble here you know what i'm
saying
um but like i said since it's a horror
movie you pretty much know that
everyone's in trouble there
and you can like pretty much call where
it's going i mean i think as soon as
they got to the theater and like all the
waiters came out with the thing and i
was just
i kind of called i was like oh i know
where this is going and it does kind of
go that way
but it's got some other weird [ __ ] going
on in there too and like i said it's
like a really
i mean just the look of it it's just i
couldn't get over how
[ __ ] gorgeous this movie was it's
just a
beautiful beautiful looking movie yeah
it's real kind of shadowy
yeah it's very very atmospheric it's
like so in all the saturated colors and
like i just i just love that kind of
sumptuous
like inside of the thing but yeah this
is um
you know it's it's not like a big
hollywood production it's not like so it
is kind of like subdued
but it does have like some you know
violence and gore and [ __ ] like that
like near the end
um it's more like a mystery i guess or
like a thriller
but like with a weird it like i said it
reminded me of eyes wide shut a little
bit
i guess just because of like the kind of
you know the the decor of the place and
the masks
were kind of eyes wide shuddish and also
because it was like a culty kind of
aspect to it sort of so it kind of
reminded me of that
but um overall like i really enjoyed it
and i would um you know like
to see what else this guy does because
like i said i think this is only your
first
his first or second movie um we were i
was thinking about some other like
norwegian horror that i've seen and i'm
pretty sure
troll hunter was norwegian wasn't it i
don't know
that was a good and that was one of one
of the few like found footage movies
that i was totally on board with that
that that
she was hilarious i think it was more
that was this is more on mockumentary
than found footage
yeah but i love it's funny the idea
of someone making a documentary and then
giant trolls are real
yeah and it's just like i loved the look
of them
like in the found footage because like
that's exactly if trolls were real
that's like exactly what they would look
like these big giant trolls and it's
just like
it's a great [ __ ] movie that one this
one like i said i didn't
love it but it's pretty good
i mean it's a pretty good uh movie
really really nice looking really
you know it's a little predictable
you'll see where it's going like pretty
much immediately but
that's okay though you know what i mean
i didn't mind it i liked it
yeah i was like pretty much intrigued to
see what was gonna happen and i'm pretty
jaded you know what i mean it takes a
lot to impress me you know but
i think if i was in a different state of
mind i'd like to better to me they're
kind of
samey all movies are kind of samey to me
now i see
i see a lot of times i see where it's
going to go you know what i mean yeah i
mean there's only so much
there's only so much you can do i mean
the problem is and plus we're old and
i don't even think it has to do with
being old i just think it has to do with
because even if you're younger and
you've seen a lot of movies
or you've read a lot of fiction there's
only so many
things that you can do you know without
just going completely out there so it
doesn't make any sense
well you know i kind of have a feeling
that uh you know
the medium of cinema is going to
rapidly shrink now that all the kobe
thing the theaters
and really only the best of it's going
to survive if you ask me
it's just it's an old medium
you know the the future i think is in
like a vr video games
virtual reality that you're immersed in
and yeah
people do seem to enjoy that it's like a
movie but you're controlling it but
you're in it and you're like involved
yeah i think that's the future
i mean some people well what are you
talking about man movies they've been
around forever
you know the movies will be forever ah
man you don't have people out there
telling epic poems like they did back in
the day
poetry isn't much of a thing anymore
it'll be around it's just it's not going
to be
it's not the future well it's just
another art form like i said
but art forms disappear over time or
they or they just get smaller
i mean look at pro sports all right pro
sports are rapidly [ __ ] shrinking
they'll always be
football you know and [ __ ] but
baseball's nearly gone
economically it will exist it just won't
be a big money maker
corporations that have been feeding off
of that are dying you know or
their businesses are dying and the
reason being is because
that came from a time where there was no
other mediums
you know yeah it's being replaced by
damn video game athletes
that's where all the money is yeah it's
ridiculous but
that's true [ __ ] evolves you know well
yeah that's just
that's how life goes that's how life is
[Laughter]
but uh yeah
how many i mean we got [ __ ] centuries
worth of good movies already made
that you can always go back and watch it
it's not like back in the day when you
didn't have your own blu-ray player or
your own vhs
player you know i mean you can save a
movie and watch it when you want to
watch it
so the old the old business model was
kind of like
it wasn't on demand they shoved it down
your throat you didn't have a choice
you couldn't go back and watch an old
movie but now that you can
the industry now competes with itself
it's just crazy to think that even in
our lifetimes
if you missed something like at the
theater or you missed it on tv
[Laughter]
the whole concept of missing it was the
incentive to go to the theater
and see it yeah everybody's just like oh
man i'll see it another day i'll wait a
month you know
that starts to be the beginning of the
end technology you know
technology's gonna eat it up and and now
modern day hollywood now has to complete
compete against itself classic hollywood
from back in the 80s and 90s
and a lot of those movies were the
writing was better back then
i mean the thing about it is like i like
to watch i like to see new movies and
but there's like still like a bunch of
old movies that i want to see that i
haven't seen yet so i like to have kind
of a balance because i don't want to be
like one of those cranky old [ __ ]
that's just kind of like oh that's
all back in my day they made all the
good stuff remember because i don't i
never wanted to be like that i listened
i listened to some of these channels
that are just experts in all this [ __ ]
that have all kinds of industry
outsiders inside the [ __ ] disney
corporation and inside the studios
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
gonna do they all believe that this is
the end of the blockbuster
that those big billion dollar
blockbusters
that maxed out that will never happen
again well i mean we've talked about
that before it's just kind of like it's
very difficult to make something that's
going to appeal to enough people
to make that much money back yeah
you know what i mean so then that means
you have to make small productions and
if you make small productions you have
to make many of them and they have to
come up and have to be produced quickly
oh i saw a shadow going i saw a shadow
go in front of the light back there i
was like what the [ __ ]
and then to put them up inside to put
them up inside
the theater system you lose a lot of
your profitability because the theaters
want their cuts
so then all of a sudden they start
saying well why don't we just put it on
a streaming service
but the streaming services are all
competing against each other well and
they're starting to make their own
original content right
right right so the entire
business is being changed in a way that
it will never recover from because
it's technology-driven change but as i
said in a way that's good because good
for us
well and because you get more in
more entertainment that's like geared
toward your taste because they're making
so much of it for niche
markets and only the best of it will
serve but it's like you know i can go on
netflix or shutter or hulu or whatever
and i can find like tons of like movies
and
series and stuff like that that have
been made like just in the past couple
years
that really look cool like that look
like my kind of [ __ ]
so you know i'll never live long enough
to see all of it it's good for us
it's not good for them that's the way
they look at it it's not
the cash cow that it was yeah but you
know it should happen
yes me [ __ ] them [ __ ] happens i think
the best of it will survive
then give me a billion dollars
[Laughter]
you're not gonna have a world where
they're just gonna pump out [ __ ] and
people are just and they're gonna make
money off of it
if they pump out [ __ ] nobody will give a
[ __ ] they'll never make any returns on
it and those people will be out of the
business
so only the best people will survive
like youtube
a lot of youtubers you know what i mean
became youtubers but they didn't survive
you know what i mean i think the average
channel only lasts a couple weeks couple
months
yeah you know and i mean the thing about
it is that once you get to a point where
you have you know x amount of
subscribers and you're actually like
starting to be sort of successful
yeah you have to put pretty much as much
work into it as you would put in this
job
yeah and i think a lot of people don't
want to do that i think a lot of people
get into it because it's fun or it's
like a side hobby
and then they're kind of like oh i'd
like to make money off of it but if you
do that you really have to put
job-like work into it otherwise you're
not going to make anything now you have
to start running it like a business
because you have to [ __ ] schedule all
the material and you got to start
producing material a lot of these guys
some of these dudes are making a huge
amount of money but they're also have to
they also have employees
yeah that's what i'm saying i mean were
you talking about really it's like you
know a show i like like um
you know blame society which is the
whole channel they do welcome to the
basement beer and board games they uh
chad vader they do all that kind of
stuff
it's like yeah they make a lot of money
like on patreon and stuff like that but
there are several of them
um working together and they do a whole
bunch of different shows
yeah and they're like professionally put
together last
i heard they're making thirty five
thousand dollars a month
wasn't that about right i don't even
remember how much it was it was a lot
but like i said they do a lot of shows
like nine of them
yeah and then there's like a whole bunch
and then all the expenses
right there's taxes yeah and that's the
thing and
and like i said they also do chad vader
which is like a fictional
like kind of show um that they do also
so it's like they they put a lot of work
in for that money it's not like they're
just like
sitting around talking into their shitty
camera and like making all that money
yeah they're real writers they've worked
on a lot of programs i think for
hollywood style stuff
they have yeah well all of them are like
comedians and they're all like
they've all had varying levels of
success on like the comedy circuit and
have written on movies and tv shows and
stuff like that
but yeah like i said another thing i
like too about uh netflix kind of coming
back to the movie that we're talking
about today is i like
um and shutter does this too they really
do seem to make an effort to get like
all the indie stuff from the
festivals and they also make an effort
to get like the best [ __ ] from like
around the world you know what i mean so
you get like the best
kind of [ __ ] of um you know from
different countries which i
actually really like to see you know
what we'd we watched that um
that russian series and we haven't done
a matinee on that yet maybe we should do
that tomorrow or tuesday or
uh wednesday whatever the [ __ ] did it i
don't know what day it is but um
yeah because i remember somebody
recommended that we should watch that
russian series to the lake and we
actually did watch that
um and i actually liked it quite a bit
so we might do it yeah
i thought it was a mixed bag it was good
and bad yeah we could we'll we can do a
matinee on tomorrow or wednesday if you
want
um i had another movie like tonight that
i wanted to watch that i think
netflix just added or no shutter just
added it i'm pretty sure
um another horror movie so i'm gonna
like uh check that one out tonight so
maybe wednesday we'll talk about
to the lake um yeah because that was
like pretty good and like i said i think
somebody recommended it
all right so everybody's in there
talking about what franchises are going
dead and [ __ ] the nails in the
coffins
yeah the blockbusters last year's
blockbusters have [ __ ] failed
and they didn't make a return and it's
the end the couf is [ __ ] knocking
[ __ ] out barbara broccoli's trying to
sell the [ __ ]
double 07 off to the [ __ ] streaming
services and she wanted
she wanted a [ __ ] ton of money for it
um top gun too what are they gonna do
with that there's a lot of [ __ ] they're
holding back
that was made for a business model that
no longer exists
top gun 2 might do well on streaming
though i imagine it will
yeah i wouldn't mind seeing it i wasn't
a huge fan of the first top gun
but um you know i'd watch it i don't
watch the second one
you know i know i know zach man he's
he's just been out of shape over [ __ ]
no time to die
he's got he's got a man crush on his
name the man crush [ __ ] zach straight up
gay
gay lust off off a [ __ ] uh off a
[ __ ] double 07
uh understandable he's trying to get
that trying to get up in that
and um i understand that but i i
i'd love the daniel craig series bond
i'm not really looking forward to this
one i just got a bad feeling about it
based on the pr that was released uh
based on the [ __ ] feedback from the
[ __ ]
uh the early screen showings had to go
back and reshoot a bunch of stuff
i don't know i don't know we'll see
because it's what they're trying to do
they're trying to make you think that
they're turned james bond into a joke
you know that he's like a relic from the
past and he's just an old man and it's
time for him to step aside and it's just
i i just get that [ __ ] bad feeling
uh about that movie and evidently the
the early screening audiences who were
james bond fans were like ah
no no no no and when that happens then
you know you're dealing with
a turd you know and i think it's gonna
be a turd i mean it's just like
terminator dark fate was a [ __ ] turd
the people that [ __ ] first saw it
didn't like it the terminator fans
didn't like it they tried to fix it it
didn't fix
same thing with that last predator movie
man that could have been really good but
it just wasn't and they they re they had
to reshoot that thing two or three times
and it's hollywood does not have the
talent that it used to have just sorry
it just doesn't
speaking of james bond we didn't even we
didn't even mention on the show that
sean
connery died yeah sean connery died but
he was 90. he that's not really dying
that's moving on that's that's making
the jump to hyperspace
you know what i mean it's time to go
when you're that easy he's wearing his
red zarda's diaper in heaven yeah
yeah yeah he's going he's being recycled
and to be reborn later on
in another place and then after carousel
he wasn't going to be here
right there's a certain
there's a there's a certain age
that you hit to where it's not really
death
yeah i'm talking about i don't see it
that way you're just kind of like
you just you translate it off into a
higher realm
[Laughter]
kind of like skywalker in that shitty
movie where he just turned into a
blanket
remember that sure yeah he poof when he
turned into a blanket that's what i want
to do when i die i'll just turn into a
blanket
i just pulled that [ __ ] out of his ass
it did look like he turned into a
blanket did he
i guess i don't really remember
he was sitting on the rock looking at
the sun and he vanished and again
and i guess it was his clothes are left
behind yeah i mean that's
it but it looked like to me like well
let's just get to it well it was just
kind of like the first it was just kind
of like the star wars like where
where vader like did the thing through
obi-wan
yeah and then his cloak just felt like
that that's what i went out like a [ __ ]
that's what i thought but like um what
was i gonna say too i was like oh well
you're you're looking forward to the
crossover movie though yeah
that looks like it's going to be cool oh
yeah what are you talking about
you mean you mean christmas chronicles 2
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
that's going to be great i'm actually
really excited i saw the trailer
yeah goldie it looks really good mrs
claus is going to be more in it
[ __ ] gold yeah she's going to be in
it the whole time i think she got her
face done that's what i heard
it looks like she she got her face done
she looks young i love
that i was reading an article today or
yesterday or something on av
club and they were talking about like
all the stuff that was coming out like
in the next couple months
and they mentioned christmas chronicles
and i love that they called uh kurt
russell and this uh
they called it his self suit yeah
you know like milf but santa
[Laughter]
that like made me laugh um but yeah like
the way they described it actually
sounds really cool
mango said i think the bob movie was
doomed when danny boyle walked away from
it yeah probably
i just have a bad feeling about it and
uh
look man part specter that was a good
place to end that that's for me that's
the end
and i'm gonna see it
but after i after i hear about it you
know what i mean if
if if people are saying it's total [ __ ]
i'm not going to soil my mind with bad
bond
i'm just going to pretend like it didn't
exist like uh
i'm just like it's like it's bad fan
fiction or something well that's your
prerogative
that's my pride
oh my god that's another shirt i have to
make i want to just put i'm going to put
that's your program but it's going to
have like turkey necks on it that
looks stupid
no one will understand that shirt that
doesn't know the [ __ ] that's okay
gotta get some like real [ __ ] up
picture of my dad
no teeth and [ __ ] oh my god
all right on that note
soon it'll be thanksgiving and we'll
have all the turkey necks we can
handle yeah all right
so that'll wrap it up for our sort of
review if we
i mean we reviewed the movie then we
just like talked about some other [ __ ]
so uh we'll be back
again tomorrow as usual talking about
another new movie
and uh thanks everybody for stopping by
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye